How’s your summer going?
Did you spend a lot of time in the pool?
Have fond memories of the ol’ swimmin’
hole?
Well, let me retroactively ruin them.
Pools are gross.
The thing about water is some pathogens absolutely
thrive in it.
Harmful viruses, bacteria, and protozoa can
be transmitted from one person to another
by way of pool water.
Over 14 years, health officials from 46 states
and Puerto Rico reported almost 500 outbreaks
linked to treated recreational water, causing
more than 27,000 illnesses and eight deaths.
Since many people don’t go to a doctor when
they’re sick, and it’s difficult to test
water for contaminants after an outbreak,
those numbers could be higher still.
Now, you may be thinking that a lot of these
outbreaks were caused by pools that weren’t
treated properly, and it’s true that does
happen remarkably often.
A 2016 CDC study found 80% of public pools
had health and safety violations.
Eighty percent!
One in eight facilities failed their inspections
so badly they were closed immediately.
Undertreated pools can lead to tragedy, like
in 1998 when seven swimmers who shared a pool
with a child with E. coli were hospitalized,
resulting in one death.
E. coli outbreaks like that can be prevented
by properly treating pools with our dear old
friend, chlorine.
The chlorine that’s added to pools, either
in the form of hypochlorous acid or hypochlorite
ions, reacts with the lipids in a microorganism’s
cell walls or enzymes inside the cells and
kills them (which is good).
But, chlorine also reacts with ammonia in
things like sweat and pee.
This results in chloramines, which are responsible
for that pool smell.
It also means there’s less free chlorine
available to kill friggin’ E. coli!
That’s right, that “chlorine smell”
and your red irritated eyes actually mean
a pool is under chlorinated, not over chlorinated!
A properly treated pool has no smell.
Yeah.
NONE.
But even if a pool is chlorinated, some pathogens
can survive, like Cryptosporidium.
This single-celled parasite has an outer shell
that makes it resistant to chlorine.
It’s the leading cause of waterborne disease
in the US, and symptoms include abdominal
pain, fever, nausea, vomiting, and diarrhea.
That last symptom is also bad for pool goers.
Diarrhea is almost always caused by some infectious
microorganism, and people can spread it in
pools up to two weeks after the symptoms subside.
Then all it takes is for another swimmer to
inadvertently swallow some infected pool water
and start the cycle anew.
Even if people haven’t had diarrhea, they
can still shed poop and it’s associated
pathogens into the pool.
One study found that the average person -- that
is, you and me -- has about 0.14 grams of
poop on our stinky bums.
That’s about the weight of one pea.
A pea’s worth of poop.
I love that I get paid to say this stuff.
Fortunately, it’s not hard to avoid becoming
a disease vector.
How many people don’t shower before getting
in a pool because they figure the pool will
wash them off?
Well turns out we were wrong.
Showering before swimming is a good way to
clean up our gross butts for everyone’s
benefit.
It also washes away sweat, so the chlorine
won’t react with it.
I can’t believe I have to say this, but
you should also avoid peeing the pools.
One survey found that one out of five people
admit to peeing in pools while four out of
five people are liars, I’m assuming.
Pee also has ammonia in it that will use up
free chlorine, making the pool smell bad and
be less safe.
Avoid swallowing the water as best you can.
And lastly if you’ve had diarrhea in the
last two weeks, do us all a favor and suntan
or read a book while the rest of us enjoy
Cryptosporidium-free water.
Have a great summer!
Not all microbes are bad… for example your
gut is filled with them.
They’re just controlling your mind, no big
deal.
Watch Maren’s video to understand how!
And one last thing, I don’t have a cool
fun fact, but have you thought about how often
we empty pools and scrub them down?
How often.
Yeah, maybe just try not to think about it.